Salut à tous c'est Pêcheurs De Trésors.
Aujourd'hui, on a trouvé une belle rivière
où on a envie de pêcher à l'aimant
Je vous propose de commencer tout de suite
Tu es prêt Quentin ?
Prêt
Le premier lancer de la journée, en direct.
Alors
Un leurre de pêche
Un spot de pêche, c'était sûr
Moi seulement ça
c'est une petite partie en plastique.
Il est beau ce leur de pêche.
Sandra
Si tu te reconnais on a ton leurre de pêche
Un deuxième leurre
C'est le même ?
A peu prêt, un peu plus vieux
OK, on est vraiment
sur un coin de pêcheur.
En tout cas.
On a changé de point.
Il y avait seulement 2 leurres de pêche là bas.
On va voir ce qu'on arrive à trouver ici.
J'ai senti des choses,
je vais aller voir
de plus près.
Je l'ai. OK.
Ah ben oui, alors ça n'a pas été fait.
C'est intéressant,
c'est intéressant.
On a pas mal d'objets différents.
Dites moi
si vous reconnaissez ce que c'est.
C'est une sorte de clous,
cette fourche là,
j'aime bien.
Non, non,
non, non.
J'ai déconné
Alors en fait, j'étais coincé parce qu'il y
a mon objet qui s'était coincé dans le bord
Et voilà.
Je l'ai eu.
C'est un couvercle,
juste un couvercle de poêle
sympa.
Allez, on va voir ce qu'on trouve d'autres
Magnifique !
Il y a un bord en béton où en acier ?
Il faut se mettre en bas pour remonter, sinon tu vas te coincer dans les rochers.
C'est un peu chiant
Les objets se coincent les rochers
C'est des objets anciens.
Oh non ! Tu l'as filmé ?
Si, c'est en fer
Elle est bonne ?
C'est une sorte de foreuse
Ça valait le coup ?
Oui, un gros foret
C'est marrant parce que c'était une chute
mais tu es tombé tout doucement.
Tu ne veux pas aller décoincer mon aimant tant que tu es dans l'eau ?
Si tu veux
Je suis attaché à ma corde
T'avais rien dans la poche ?
Il y a des huîtres ici.
Comment tu t'es débrouillé pour glisser ?
Tout seul
C'est bon.
Merci,
Tu sent carrément les objets en marchant dessus ?
Je sent des trucs au sol,
des plaques de fer.
Ouah !
Oui, c'est bon, je vais l'attraper.
Ca glisse
c'est bon,
bien joué.
Et voilà le pêcheur de trésor trempé
Le foret, il est sympa
Une lampe à pile, tu sais les grosses lampes
Regarde la taille de la pile.
Remonte le mien aussi
C'est bien de la sortir de l'eau.
Ouais belle dépollution.
Bon à toi le jeune.
On va voir ce que tu as de beau ?
Oh un cadenas !
OK, c'est bon signe
Bien joué
OK. C'est u morceau de mobylette je crois
Oui
Aussi une boucle de ceinture.
Ouais, c'est une grosse boucle de ceinture, ça.
Joli
Allez, on a quelque chose, un bon poids.
OK, une grosse visse
Oh, ce ne serait pas un clip de munitions ?
Avec quatre munitions
C'est des grosses ça.
C'est du gros calibre
On va regarder ensemble.
S'il y a des inscriptions,
il y en a une qui a l'air bien conservée.
Elles sont cuivrées.
Elles datent clairement de la guerre.
C'est clairement dans l'eau depuis
la guerre, vu l'état.
ça fait vraiment plaisir en tout cas.
Quentin a un gros objet qui vient enfin.
Qu'est ce que c'est ça, un vélo ?
Ouais.
Il n'est pas tout neuf.
Il est coincé, tiens
Je vais en haut
Oui, moi je vais soulever l'arrière
Celui-là est dans l'eau depuis un moment
Bien joué.
Il est vieux
Il y a une lampe dynamo.
Belle trouvaille
Bon, ça commence bien.
Ouais, on continue.
De la vieille ferronnerie.
Sympa, sympa.
J'aime toujours ces objets relativement anciens
avec des jolies formes.
C'est cool.
J'ai un bel objet au bout de l'aimant
je retourne ma casquette pour me porter chance et on regarde
Elle est longue !
OK, une longue barre.
Il y a un filet de pêche accroché
C'était peut être du matériel de pêcheur.
Elle est belle.
Sympa,
Belle trouvaille. Une fourche.
Elle est entière, il y a tous les piques
On a pas trop d'objets récents pour l'instant.
Une chaîne de vélo, peut être de mon vélo
d'ailleurs.
Ah bah oui, elle est cassée.
Oui, c'est celle de mon vélo.
Tu peux la réparer
Oui, réparer une chaîne rouillée...
Je ne suis pas sûr
Qu'est ce que j'ai d'intéressant là ?
C'est pas très vieux
Ah non,
C'est des freins de vélo.
On peut être encore de mon vélo.
Et oui, également une cuillère de pêche,
comme disait Baptiste
en bon état.
Et ça,
Ca a la forme d'un pistolet
Je crois que c'est un pistolet
des enfants
C'est pas possible.
Ah ben ça, c'est un chien d'arme
Un pistolet velodog ?
Un mini pistolet
Franchement, j'ai vraiment
l'impression.
Aussi petit c'est fou !
Le pistolet !
Il est fossilisé.
J'ai trouvé une arme
Bien joué
Pistolet de cycliste calibre 22 flobert, fin du XIXème siècle
Le chien, ça trompe pas comme ça.
Tout le reste tu ne reconnais pas
Il est dans l'eau depuis 100 ans.
OK, cool.
Quentin a trouvé un vieux pistolet à chien
On va voir ce qu'on arrive à faire
de mieux, mais c'est vrai que là
la barre est très haute.
Ben alors la stagiaire ?
Tu enchaînes ici ?
Tu vas tomber à l'eau comme ça
Une pelle cassée
Je ne vais plus être stagiaire à force
Au bout d'un moment tu ne le seras plus
Je pêche mieux que vous maintenant
Si tu fais une belle trouvaille,
on demandera si tu n'es plus stagiaire.
Il faut qu'ils répondent en commentaire.
Ok, on a déjà quelque chose au bout de l'aimant
On va essayer de le ramener avant qu'il
ne se coince dans les rochers,
donc on va le faire voler
tout simplement.
On va regarder ensemble
ce qu'on a
Une grille fluviale ?
Peut être que c'est
juste pour le barbecue.
Une lame de rasoir
Quentin est presque retombé
tout à l'heure, c'était très drôle.
Une petite glissade encore sur les fesses.
C'était rempli !
Oui il y a plein de choses mais effectivement ce n'est
pas facile de pêcher ici
parce que ça glisse beaucoup.
On a assisté à une chute déjà,
mais il y en aura peut être d'autres
En espérant avoir mieux que des clous.
Ca doit venir d'un outil ancien
Avec ce crochet
Ah non, c'est simplement un ancien porte manteau
Regarde le porte manteau ancien, comme il y avait dans les écoles.
Ah oui, un porte cartable peut être
Une cuillère de pêche
et encore un gros boulon
Une grille de barbecue
C'est la deuxième
J'espère que j'ai mieux
que cette grille de barbecue.
On va regarder tout de suite,
peut être.
Oh, comme il est rempli !
Oh ! Des munitions !
Regarde ça
C'est le genre de spot
au cœur de village,
où quelqu'un pourrait venir te voir
et te dire ici
après la guerre, on a jeté ça
C'est vrai que ça ne doit pas être souvent à sec là.
Ça, c'est quoi ?
Vachette ? C'était un cadenas.
Il a été cassé.
Ah ouais, cassé aussi ? Ouvert
Je pêche un peu avec toi là.
Mais je vais finir à l'eau,
alors je peux pas rester longtemps.
Tu aimes bien dires "la stagiaire" ça t'excite
Possible.
C'est ton premier vélo ?
Ouais
Je te le tient si tu veux enlever ton aimant
C'est un vélo très sympa,
mais pas en tire.
Un cadre de vélo on va dire.
OK, bien joué
Sur le côté tu vas choper plein de choses.
Presque la chute.
Tu ne l'auras pas la chute, tu l'auras pas.
Je suis là pour ça.
Oh c'est quoi ça ? C'est pas un fusil ? Non
ça aurait pu
Il y a un gros truc qui vient.
il est resté là bas.
Regardez toutes les bulles,
c'est bon signe.
Ouais, ça soulève. - C'est gros
Ouais.
C'est bon, il a bougé.
Il faut descendre
Tu veux descendre ?
Je vais descendre, soulever, tu tires d'en haut
C'est un bout de banc public je crois
Oui tu as raison, c'est ça un morceau de vieux banc
Un ancien pied de banc
Ils ont été changés ceux là, ça se voit
Alors qu'est ce qu'on a de beau ?
Un peu de poids.
Une pelle de cheminée,
mais surtout un galet.
Ah non, c'est bizarre, ce n'est pas un galet aimanté
C'est comme du marbre
Enfin une pierre avec un morceau de rouille dessus,
fossilisé
Original.
Et voilà une pelle à cheminé.
Il y a un truc.
Oh, c'est un morceau de mobylette
ou quoi ?
Déjà il y a une anse de seau
Ca je ne sais pas trop ce que c'est
Si vous savez ce que c'est en commentaire.
Une anse de seau où de chaudron ?
De chaudron.
Le chaudron doit être dedans alors
Peut être
Oui, peut être que j'ai touché le chaudron
parce qu'il y avait un gros truc.
Donc ça peut être drôle.
Oh, sympa.
Un marteau.
C'est à la pointe qui est encore avec ?
Non, non, c'est juste un clou.
OK, mais il est cool
Il est restaurable, juste à changer le manche
et enlever la rouille
Quentin a trouvé un marteau.
Qu'est ce qu'on a nous ?
Encore une anse de chaudron.
Une deuxième
Il s'est passé un truc ici avec les seaux et les chaudrons.
Qu'est ce qu'on a de beau ?
Oh, il y a écrit un truc
C'est un morceau de bruleur
Ouais, anneau de combustion
En gros, c'est un morceau de gazinière, elle est
bien ancienne vu ce qu'il y a écrit
C'est rempli, c'est rempli.
Encore des munitions.
Quatre d'un coup.
Tiens, je te les dédicace celle là.
Oh, merci
On continue, tant qu'il y a des munitions
et des choses à remonter.
On a déjà une dizaine de munitions
facilement
Quentin vient de remonter un vélo.
Et moi, je remonte pendant ce temps,
des dizaines de munitions
en un seul lancer.
Et bien écoute qu'il le garde son vélo.
Elle était sur des clips.
Donc tu rentres ton clip
entier de munitions dedans
Des clips avec 7 où 8 munitions
C'est très stylé ça.
Normalement, c'est de l'allemand.
Comme disait
Quentin, c'est le surement du Kar98
En séchant elle deviennent très moches
N.F
1939 du coup, c'est logique
C'est peut être français alors
Dites nous en commentaire mais le "F"
Pour moi c'est français et c'est bien
de la guerre, donc c'est très stylé.
Espérons qu'ils aient laissé l'arme
un, deux, trois.
Il faut être plus nombreux, où utiliser le treuil
Ah ouais, parfait.
C'est bon, on a de l'aide
Il va bouger à quatre
un, deux trois.
Il a lâché
Il avait l'air lourd.
C'est un piège ?
Non, c'est un morceau de bruleur
J'ai cru que c'était un piège.
Ca y ressemblait
C'est peut être une cuisinière
Oh, encore un bout de banc public, non ?
C'est un morceau de mobylette Solex
Une partie de la fourche ? Du cadre ?
C'est la béquille
Il y a peut être un petit Solex
quelque part.
Bon, qu'est ce qui se passe ici ?
Qu'est ce que vous nous faites ?
Je suis bloquée
Même les chiens, ils sont inquiets.
C'est quoi ce bordel là ?
On est bloqué avec un aimant
On ne sait pas trop si c'est sûr un objet où un rocher
Baptiste essaye donc de débloquer l'aimant
Puisque en tirant, ça ne marche pas.
Un anneau de tonneau.
Cerclage de tonneaux.
Un gros anneau gastrique
Exactement.
Très bien.
Elle apprend vite
Bravo !
Un anti vole de vélo
Je vais chercher le treuil, on arrête de perdre du temps
Il est entre deux rochers, c'est
soit on arrive à le repêcher, soit on va dans l'eau
Même le treuil ne sert à rien si c'est le mauvais angle
Donc il arrive l'homme de la situation,
Justement,
Il y a plusieurs solutions.
La première, c'est de traverser
et de tirer d'en face.
Donc c'est vrai que ça aurait
été possible ici en envoyant les aimants.
Mais Quentin avait un peu chaud,
donc bon...
Et puis.
Aussi.
C'est à Quentin de prendre en charge
la gestion de l'aimant de la stagiaire.
Surtout, c'est
son maître de stage
C'était des rochers
il est sorti direct ? Ouais
Là, je t'emmène ton aimant loin
Attention aux crocodiles.
Aux vipères surtout
Ah oui, aux serpents !
Allez, attention, la tête,
AAAAh
Ah, ça y est, elle a coincée !
Non, c'est que c'est aimanté là
c'est pas facile.
S'il y a toute la canalisation,
c'est lourd, ça va vient ?
La stagiaire a quelque chose.
Ah oui, encore une comme ça là
... Il y en a plein de ces barres
Bien joué
Une vue de dessous de la stagiaire.
Oula qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?
ça a lâché ?
Donne moi ton aimant Baptiste je vais le déposer plus loin
Attends j'ai quelque chose, je pense
J'ai quelque chose
Juste un anneau
et une lame de couteau.
Ah oui, oui, couteau rond
Non, sûrement une arme de meurtre.
Non, ça, c'est Mi rond
Quentin va emmener l'aimant tout au fond
Ne me tire pas par contre
On est bon
regardez comme c'est beau.
On a quelque chose
Oh non j'ai fais comme toi.
Oh purée. Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
C'est un plat pour cuisiner ça
Tu sais,
il a été écrasé, totalement aplatis
Comment tu peux faire ça ?
Pauvre faitout
Oh non, je relâche la ferraille.
Ah oui, oui.
Toujours le même genre de choses.
Les ressort, ça,
j'en fais plein à ce moment là.
Il y a un sommier quelque part peut-être
ça force à on voit les muscles...
Fais voir les veines du biceps
Il est balaise
ça a lâché ?
Baptiste, ça y est, c'est
un gros truc encore
Comme ça bulle
Allez ça vient
Oui, le vélo, j'en étais sûr.
Enfin vu comment j'étais coincée...
Bon. Bien joué pour ceux qui se demandent
nos aimants viennent
du site de maison de la détection.
Nous, on utilise le barbarian 1600 kilos
qui attire sur une surface de 360 degrés.
Mais vous avez différentes gammes
sur leur site.
En général, pour débuter,
on conseille le Terror.
Toutes les infos
sont la description de la vidéo
et vous avez le code promo
Pêcheur de Trésor qui offre 58%
sur toute la boutique,
y compris sur les détecteurs de métaux.
Va essayer de faire un tour avec même si la chaîne risque de se casser
Super bravo Jade.
Merci
City 30 top bike. OK.
Je vais dans la descente avec ?
Non, je pense que tu n'iras nul part avec
Il est bloqué à l'arrière, Non ?
Vous allez vraiment l'essayer ? Oui.
On est obligés
Si tu pédales
ça peut marcher.
Bon, oui,
oh non, ça ne marchera pas.
La roue arrière est bloquée
On a trouvé un problème de freins.
Et la roue est tordue
Dommage.
J'ai quelque chose qui.
Encore un anneau gastrique.
C'est fou,
Pas une seule munition.
C'était mieux là bas pour les munitions.
c'est de la fonte,
On a un sacré poids en ferraille là Baptiste
Faut trouver un ferrailleur sur le trajet,
T'es coincée, tu penses ?
Mais là, c'est pas aimanté
Ouais, je vais voir
Tu veux que je nage ?
Ouais
Tire tire !
Entre l'aimant et un bout de fer
il y avait morceaux de faïence.
Faïencerie de
je ne sais pas, mais je suis sûr qu'un
abonné reconnaîtra avec le logo
dîtes nous en commentaires
C'est une assiette, je pense.
On est là, on était coincé, mais on a trouvé
un piège, donc c'est cool.
Un petit piège,
c'est pour les rongeurs ça
Il a sauté dans l'eau ?
Il est tombé non ?
Il est tombé ?
T'es tombé ?
Mais il est où ? Il a coulé
Hein ?
Tu es tombé ?
C'est moi qui ais les clefs ?
Non c'est bon elles sont dans le sac, t'es tombé.
Ahaha tu t'es fais mal ?
Tu t'es pas fais mal ? Non
C'est l'endroit ou j'étais tombé, Non ?
A l'endroit ou il y avait la vipère
Tu t'ai pas fait mal, c'est le principal.
On a entendu, on a dit il est tombé.
Heureusement, je n'avais plus les clés.
Ça, c'est l'aimant ?
Vas y
Alors attends je monte
Je pense que le plouf va s'entendre a la caméra
Parce que filmais... Ah bon tu me filmes là ? oui oui
Je filmais aussi quand tu es tombé, on a entendu plouf
Tu vois, fallait pas se moquer de moi.
Lui aussi est tombé en fin de vidéo.
En plus
Il n'y a que Jade qui ne tombe pas
Ouais bon, j'aurais peut être pas dû.
Autant me moquer de Quentin,
ça va elle n'est pas trop froide, je me suis pas
fait mal, c'est le principal
et du coup par contre
Ilo faut que je finisse par remonter cet aimant
Regardez,
il est beau, dîtes nous en commentaire
les connaisseurs de poisson.
ce que ça peut-être
Strip tease
C'est ça ? En fait,
je suis coincé sur un rocher.
Ah oui, tu as tiré un coup sec. Oui comme ça
et ça m'a fait rebondir.
Et ça m'a dit Bah oui,
Tête la première du coup ?
Du coup.
Je sais pas trop,
J'ai pas le filme, C'est dommage.
Ahaha oui
Quentin m'a emmené l'aimant au fond
et il m'a décroché
puisque quand je suis tombé dans l'eau
Juste ici c'est parce que
j'étais coincé et j'ai voulu tirer.
La corde m'a rappelé dans l'eau.
Bon, voilà, je suis tombé à à cinq minutes
d'arrêter de pêcher à l'aimant
C'est un peu dommage pour le
trajet en voiture, mais bon, ça arrive
Quentin qui se fout de ma gueule
parce que je me suis bien moqué
de lui, de ses chutes
C'est pas grave,
on garde le sourire.
Attends
Il va tomber de nouveau
Ne me tombe pas dessus cette fois
C'est vachement lourd. t'as un beau bébé.
Attends
Je l'ai perdu juste ici
Mais j'en ai un autre,
j'en ai encore un peu.
Oh oui, c'est un cadenas.
Oui, un vieux, Un vieux.
Très vieux cadenas
avec la clé à l'intérieur.
Oh. Tu sais, il a la clé
et il y a le cache clé.
Trop stylé là là.
La pêche à l'aimant naturiste à ne pas reproduire,
Et comme dirait Bondi : Magnet Away
Pour combien tu goutes ça ?
La salade ?
C'est la salade que tu oublies
dans le bac à légumes pendant six mois.
Après je t'aiderai à remonter, peut-être
Attends ne monte pas avec des algues dessus.
Qu'est-ce-que tu nous pêche là ?
Je ne l'avais pas celui-là !
Allez hop, dans la collection
Attention
magnet Away.
Ah oui, bien là,
il y a un abonné qui pêche avec nous
qui vient de faire un demi franc
50 centimes de franc 1969
Bravo, belle trouvaille !
Allez.
Une dernière remontée.
OK, c'est pas le mot de la fin,
c'est la fourchette de la fin.
Ouais,
arrête de bécoter avec les stagiaires
et n'hésitez pas à me dire
comme d'habitude en commentaire
si vous voulez que Quentin attrape
des champignons
a ses orteils,
il a encore les chaussures mouillées
et moi aussi on vous tiendra au courant
dans les commentaires.
Une belle pêche encore le camion est
bien rempli.
Ça ira donc chez le ferrailleur
pour être recyclé aussi
à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo. De pêche à l'aimant